Mila, Montréal and Canada
play a leading role at the intersection
of scientific advances in AI
and the governance required
to ensure its ethical
and socially responsible deployment.
Mila is proud to have more than 1,000
student researchers
and 100 professors,
including 53 Canada CIFAR AI Chairs
who have come together
as a community
dedicated
to scientific excellence and innovation.
Our teams work closely with industry,
encouraging the adoption
of AI by Canadian businesses.
As an example, our applied
learning programs have reached
more than 3500 managers
and technical staff
in Canadian SME’s
and large organizations.
In addition
to contributing
to economic impact for Canadians,
social responsibility
and social good
are central to Mila’s values.
We are dedicated to ensuring that
AI yields benefits for citizens, society
as a whole, and the planet.
Our AI for Humanity team is
ambitious in its response
to the increasing opportunities and risks
posed by AI.
Mila takes on projects
dedicated to advancing the greater good,
addressing challenges
such as diversity and the climate crisis,
in addition
to running training
opportunities focused on ethics in AI.
Our scientific director,
Yoshua Bengio, is very involved
on the global stage,
meeting with world leaders
to ensure
that governments
are taking the necessary steps
to manage
and regulate this powerful technology.
We believe that diversity in talent
and expertise is crucially important
to preventing bias
and enabling a technology
that represents everyone.
That's why last year alone, Mila
and the other institutes
through the Pan-Canadian AI Strategy
offered 30 programs
specifically focused on equity,
diversity and inclusion.
This is an important
and exciting time for Mila, for Montréal
and for Canada
to lead the world in the new age of AI.